outside minsk's hotels iraqi migrants
sold out back home and carrying
everything that they have wonder which
eu border to aim for
belarus has been handing out thousands
of tourist visas mostly to iraqis and
kurds promising a sure-fire way of
getting into the eu
but the eu's cottoned on and it's
getting much harder to get through
that's what i'll say we went through the
forests and reached the lithuanian
border this man tells me when we arrived
there commandos in black approached and
were aggressive they took us from where
we and the kids had stayed all night in
the cold and drove us back to the
belarussian side
the eu calls this a cynical and
well-organized act of hybrid aggression
this video according to the lithuanians
shows the belarusian border guard
escorting migrants to the border then
reversing before he's seen
it's certainly similar to the vehicle
they used to escort us there a fairly
useless trip to try and convey the
message it's the eu not belarus which is
treating migrants badly
this part of the border that they've
brought us to is properly fenced it's
going to be pretty difficult to try and
cross there but most of it is a line in
the ground like this in amongst thick
forest that is lithuania over there and
most of the migrants 4 000 have crossed
that way but that's now dried up because
the lithuanians are patrolling it more
which means people are now trying to
cross to poland and latvia instead
a group we met sent videos from the
latvian border they've been stuck there
for eight days between the latvians who
won't let them in and the bella russians
who won't allow them back today
lativians get for us some clothes for
kids only for kids
and we are in lativia's side
see this is the belarusian side and they
didn't accept us to go back home civil
after promising to flood the eu with
drugs and migrants now president
lukashenko calls them the only tools he
has to respond to eu sanctions
migrant camps at the lithuanian border
are already filling up and not a single
asylum request has been granted so far
there are plenty of people from other
countries too afghans among them people
who'd fled before kabul fell to the
taliban
[Music]
now so many more will try to flee and as
the eu wonders how to manage an
inevitable wave of desperate afghan
refugees it knows it has a wild card on
its eastern flank looking for any which
way he can find to cause trouble
magnesium
minsk